I nostri migliori supercomputer classici stanno diventando sempre più potenti,
e stiamo migliorando nel campo del calcolo, inclusa la simulazione di sistemi.
Ma simulare la natura è in generale un problema molto difficile.
Mi chiamo Victoria Lipinska e oggi esploreremo uno degli algoritmi
che potrebbe rendere possibile simulare la natura su un computer quantistico.
Iniziamo con un esempio e prendiamo in considerazione la caffeina.
È una molecola semplice.
Per rappresentare la configurazione energetica di una sola molecola di caffeina,
avremmo bisogno di circa dieci alla potenza di 48 bit.
È dieci con 48 zeri
ed è circa il 10% del numero di atomi presenti sulla Terra.
E in realtà le cose peggiorano.
Se hai 125 orbitali e vuoi memorizzare tutte le possibili
configurazioni, hai bisogno di più memoria
nel tuo computer classico di quanti atomi ci siano nell'universo.
È impossibile rappresentarlo con i supercomputer.
C'è però speranza per i computer quantistici,
perché sono intrinsecamente bravi a simulare la natura.
Per una molecola di caffeina, ciò significherebbe rappresentare
il sistema usando 160 qubit.
Sembra molto più gestibile.
Sono stati proposti vari algoritmi quantistici che permettono
a computer quantistici più piccoli di simulare la natura in modo euristico.
Ecco: il variational quantum eigensolver, o VQE.
Il VQE è un algoritmo che gira in parte su un computer quantistico
e in parte su un computer classico.
Ci permette di trovare valori che risolvono un dato problema di ottimizzazione.
Il VQE è strettamente correlato ad altri metodi che prevedono
la variazione di parametri, come il quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Identificare le applicazioni del VQE nel tuo settore o nella tua ricerca
è in parte un'arte, ma esistono alcune linee guida di massima.
In generale, il VQE è applicabile a problemi che possono essere formulati
come un problema di ottimizzazione con variabili continue.
È questo il caso, ad esempio, in gran parte della chimica quantistica.
Molto spesso, in chimica, siamo interessati allo stato fondamentale.
Lo stato fondamentale è lo stato di energia minima del sistema.
Per trovare l'energia dello stato fondamentale, il VQE esplora
l'energia per diverse configurazioni del sistema
e cerca la configurazione a energia più bassa.
A grandi linee, il VQE riceve in input una descrizione del sistema quantistico
e cerca l'energia più bassa.
Lo fa variando la configurazione del sistema.
Per iniziare, dobbiamo fornire in input una descrizione appropriata del sistema
che il computer quantistico possa comprendere e un insieme di parametri che lo descrivono
e che verranno ottimizzati.
La parte quantistica
dell'algoritmo prepara il sistema in uno stato
descritto da un dato insieme di parametri e calcola l'energia.
Mentre la parte classica è responsabile
dell'ottimizzazione di quei parametri a ogni passo.
Questo processo quantistico-classico viene ripetuto
finché non raggiungiamo l'energia più bassa.
Ora concentriamoci su ciò che avviene dietro le quinte.
La configurazione energetica è tipicamente descritta nell'Hamiltoniano
ed è tipicamente una matrice molto grande.
In algebra, per trovare l'autovalore minimo della matrice
corrispondente all'energia più bassa del sistema,
eseguiremmo semplicemente la decomposizione ai valori singolari.
Tuttavia, le matrici che prenderemo in esame sono di dimensioni esponenziali
ed è un problema esponenzialmente difficile risolverlo algebricamente.
Questo Hamiltoniano deve essere rappresentato nella forma
che il computer quantistico può comprendere.
Quindi tradotto dal linguaggio della chimica al linguaggio del calcolo quantistico.
Non preoccuparti dei dettagli, però.
In definitiva esistono metodi programmabili per tradurre l'Hamiltoniano tipicamente
usato in chimica in un Hamiltoniano comprensibile per un computer quantistico.
Forniamo quindi in input questo
Hamiltoniano insieme al circuit, che chiamiamo forma variazionale.
Scegliere una forma variazionale è in parte un'arte.
Ancora,
rappresenta la nostra miglior stima di quale potrebbe essere lo stato quantistico del sistema.
Questo circuit variazionale è parametrizzato con un insieme di parametri theta,
e forniamo anche una scelta iniziale di questi parametri.
Sulla base di questo, la parte quantistica del VQE:
prepara lo stato di riferimento, ad esempio lo stato zero;
usa un circuit quantistico parametrizzato, la forma variazionale, per preparare uno stato quantistico
con una stima iniziale dei parametri sul computer quantistico; e stima
l'energia corrispondente allo stato valutato attraverso l'Hamiltoniano.
Questa stima dell'energia viene poi fornita
all'ottimizzatore classico, che trova un nuovo insieme di parametri.
I parametri tornano di nuovo al risolutore quantistico,
e l'intero processo viene ripetuto.
Il computer quantistico trova una nuova stima dell'energia,
l'ottimizzatore classico trova un nuovo insieme di parametri, e così via.
Ripetiamo questo processo finché la soluzione non converge.
Cioè finché la differenza nei risultati tra un passo e l'altro non è sufficientemente piccola
per le nostre esigenze.
Alla fine, l'algoritmo restituisce quell'energia minimizzata.
Bene, questo è ottimo.
Ma potresti chiederti come facciamo a sapere che questo funziona davvero
e che non troveremo accidentalmente un'energia inferiore a quella che stiamo cercando?
È un'ottima domanda.
Si scopre che non possiamo mai stimare un'energia inferiore.
Questo grazie a qualcosa che chiamiamo principio variazionale.
Il principio variazionale afferma che il limite inferiore più grande
dell'energia del sistema è sempre la sua
energia più bassa corrispondente a quello stato fondamentale.
Ciò significa che l'energia valutata su qualsiasi altro stato di quel sistema
sarà sempre maggiore dell'energia più bassa.
Pertanto, con il VQE non possiamo mai ottenere qualcosa
al di sotto dell'energia dello stato fondamentale.
Tuttavia, possiamo effettivamente convergere verso qualcosa
di maggiore rispetto al minimo che stiamo cercando.
Questo viene spesso chiamato soluzione metastabile
ed è una sfida che i ricercatori cercano di risolvere ogni giorno.
Il VQE è utile perché utilizza circuit più superficiali
rispetto ad altri protocolli che ci permettono di stimare l'energia dello stato fondamentale.
Questo lo rende adatto all'hardware quantistico a breve termine.
In questo video, abbiamo avuto un'idea di cosa può fare il VQE e di come è costruito.
Ma ti incoraggio a esplorare Qiskit in questo contesto.
Anche se siamo ancora all'inizio del nostro percorso quantistico,
potresti già trovarlo utile per i problemi che stai cercando di risolvere.
Mi chiamo Victoria Lipinska e questa è stata una panoramica
dell'algoritmo variational quantum eigensolver.